the most romantic scene in riverdale
would have to be i'm the biggest shony
shipper captain of the ship between
archie and veronica and betty and
jughead i think though those were sort
of the most romantic periods i really
love that relationship i don't know
what's gonna happen i don't write the
show don't yell at me it's a lot of
pressure
wait what do you mean sorry
what i remember most about shooting the
pilot probably the moment with me betty
and archie walking out into the dance
hall i feel like that was a very iconic
moment that really stuck with me i think
the thing that sticks out to me most
about the pilot is i mean it was my
first ever television show it was my
first time on a movie set i remember
being such a noob on set i had no idea
what i was doing but the first day kami
lily and i worked together and it was
very exciting and serendipitous it was
casey's first day on a set i think maybe
ever and i bought him a mcdonald's hash
brown on the way to work one day and he
was like oh this is like
i don't know it's just like a cute acute
moment it's actually really good fresh
everything was fresh being on set was
was just a fresh feeling that i'll never
get ever again and i remember when i
first stepped on the pop set that very
iconic neon lighting it was set up in a
really really wonderful sort of
picturesque way the scene where i'm in
the water i really remember that i was
cold when we're walking down the hallway
talking about how betty and rtr end game
and and so i always think of that moment
all the time with the three of us i
think the thing that sticks out to me
most is the building of relationships
that are now my family members i don't
know i feel like it's like what don't i
remember about it but i think about the
pilot a lot and and how far away that
feels from today but um i think of it
very fondly is that so impossible to
imagine
the most romantic scene in riverdale
would have to be when archie and betty
kiss for the first time in the car i
think first season did a good job really
establishing the romance the kind of
slow burns that we had between archie
and veronica and betty and jughead i
think those were sort of the most
romantic periods obviously 315 the
shoney sex scene from the biggest shony
shipper captain of the ship cheryl and
tony at the conversion camp when she
like runs up and saves her from the camp
and kisses her that's why i'm antique
scene uh veronica and reggie betty and
jughead's musical number when they sing
17. can't we be seventeen
i thought that was like the most
romantic moment of the show for sure
when they were performing the song 17
and it had all of our young heroes and
lovers singing the song to one another
and it was so passionate and everyone
was fully committing and everyone was
really singing with their real voices
and i found it very moving and it was
very romantic at the same time
[Music]
honestly i've always thought the most
romantic scene is when betty and jughead
are singing 17 together in season three
i just have always thought that was such
a beautiful scene it's a beautiful
moment between the two of them as a
couple and the song is really beautiful
it's funny because they're dancing
around in a trailer that's like a drug
lab so it's a little ironic but it still
just so happens to be a very beautiful
moment between the two of them don't you
want a life with
i have not watched all of the scenes
from riverdale but i will say out of the
scenes that i personally shot probably
when jughead jones sweeps her off her
feet and they are slow dancing and
singing to each other riverdale's most
romantic scene was probably when moose
and kevin discovered jason's dead body
in sweetwater river let's start with
skinny dipping
and then see what happens
which riverdale relationship am i still
shipping um
kevin and fangs kevin and fans i'm still
shipping there i'm still shipping
kevin and fangs i really love that
relationship kang's
seven
i'm still shipping tony and cheryl i'm
gonna have to say shoney i guess
obviously that one's my favorite shoney
forever i will never stop shipping
shoney i did like chenervo though too
cheryl the minerva shenerva but shoney's
better i can't say which relationships
i'm shipping these days because people
will
want to cut my head off no matter what i
say you have barchy fans and you have
bug head fans and they both hate each
other and are
desperate for their own ship to work out
so i'm like i don't know how it's gonna
end i don't know what's gonna happen i
don't write the show don't yell at me
i'm still trying to ship pop tate with
someone i think pop tate needs to get
out there i think he needs to maybe get
a tinder or something do not give up
either of you i can fix this
i think archie may have had the craziest
journey
over 100 episodes just when you get in
when you like think about being attacked
by a bear that's just kind of takes the
cake over everything else achieves had
the craziest journey craziest journey
was i said archie but
everyone's journey sure i'll blossom of
course
i feel like every person should say that
about their character though probably
cheryl cheryl i mean
her dead brother and having the corpse
you know in the house and all that stuff
is pretty crazy honestly i think betty
the fact that she was put in a hole by
the trash bag killer for however many
days that just seems like a lot to deal
with on all fronts probably betty
i would say
she's gone through quite a bit betty has
definitely had the craziest journey on
this show
she's like lost a million family members
and uh
or they're just in jail
um yeah they're dead or in jail she's
been through a lot that one betty
has lost most of her family
and has seen a lot of death right before
her eyes and has solved so many
mysteries i think she inherently has
experienced a lot throughout 100
episodes
isn't that kind of the point
the 100th episode is a cultivation of
the 99 episodes prior it explodes into
a whole new world
and at the same time brings us all back
to square one nothing's off the table
no one is safe everyone's a savage
they're living in this good versus evil
world that really brings out the worst
in everybody world's colliding blast
from the past um a bit of suspense and a
mind-blowing final moment get ready to
see somebody from an alternate universe
riverdale
on steroids alternate universe
um
yeah anything's fair game it is
incredibly clever and really and really
well done i think it's it's so different
from all the other episodes it's very
much a special episode and very
different from any other episode that
we've done it's complicated it's very
technical story-wise
and character-wise
uh and time-wise it explains a lot of
the
narrative insanity
that we have in camp
throughout each season it breaks the
fourth wall in the sense that it
acknowledges itself and that it's a kind
of a comic book in a way it's definitely
going to be an episode where you have to
zone in pay a lot of attention to what's
going on it does a good job sort of
wrapping up why
the events take place the way they're
sort of taking place
and why the characters all take it so so
seriously it's a
a multiverse
world
uh coming together i don't know how to
explain it the 100th episode is kind of
an episode for fans it seems much more
like a meta conversation between the
writers and the fan base and it i i
think it answers a lot of narrative
questions or at least tonal questions
about the show
which i think is uh i think is really
exciting this is a great way to explain
the 100th episode i couldn't even
explain the craziness that's happening
and i've read the script and i'm
shooting it so good luck that's pretty
good